Taylor: Good afternoon.
My name is Jamie Taylor,
and, uh, this afternoon,
um, to wrap things up,
we're going to talk
a little bit more
about, uh, using Freebase
and MQL.
Um, this is, um, a talk
which is really sort of trying
to move your use of MQL ahead,
um, some of advanced
sort of techniques.
And, um, I know
that not everybody here
is probably,
um, completely versed in MQL
and as facile
as, uh, some people,
so I thought it would be useful
to actually do
a little bit of a level set,
um, to make sure that everybody
was sort of thinking
about things the same way
and everybody was familiar
with the syntax
and some of the capabilities
of the query language.
So we'll start by talking
a little but about Freebase,
um, understanding how MQL works,
uh, some of the different forms
that it takes,
and then we're gonna push ahead
and really look quite closely
at how links are actually formed
and all of the metadata
around links, um, in Freebase.
And that's really going to be
sort of the heart or the power
in, um, this talk.
And given
what we've learned about,
uh, how links are actually
represented in Freebase,
this really suggests
a different way
of conceptualizing
your programming model,
um, when you're working
with Freebase data,
and so we'll talk a little bit
about what I call
property-driven programming.
And then finally, to wind up,
um, we'll talk about metaschema,
which is a fairly new concept,
um, in Freebase.
Uh, and the idea is that you can
actually get more power
by rolling things together.
So with that,
um, I should point out that,
um, I would really if you have
feedback about this talk,
uh, to use the short link.
Um, I'll have these available--
uh, at the end of the talk,
as well--
um, and hashtags
that people are using
when they're in
their social networks.
Um, I should also say
that, um, the slides
may not be sort of
as easily viewable,
but, um, at the end,
I will give you a URL,
uh, that actually takes you
to an acre application where
all the queries are available
and you can actually explore
them and edit them yourselves,
so you don't have to worry
about taking notes
and things like that.
So, uh, let's start by talking
a little bit about Freebase.
Uh, so you're probably aware
that Freebase
is a giant graph of entities.
Um, so here we're looking
at the neighborhood
around, uh, Jane Austen.
Um, she was an author
who was born in a town
in E-England
and wrote a couple of books,
and she's influenced
a few people,
uh, over her lifetime.
Um, what's unique about Freebase
is that all of these links
between these entities
are actually labels
that we can actually tell you
what type of relationship
they have, uh, with one another.
And this graph is fairly large.
Uh, so right now
there are over 22 million topics
in Freebase--
these are the entities--
uh, and over
400 million connections
between those 20 million--
22 million, uh, entities.
Everything in Freebase
is available
under a Creative Commons
attribution license.
So you're free to use it
in any way that you see fit,
uh, as long as you give credit
back to where the data
came from,
which I find very interesting
about Freebase, as well.
And this is really where
the--the community
contribution part,
I think, kicks in
in a very interesting way,
is that Freebase
is a very rich, uh, source
of vocabulary,
that is for ways of actually
talking about entities.
So here I've just, um,
created a simple graph
where I've, um,
ranked the instances,
um, that use types--
types being sort of collections
of attributes--
and looked at all of these types
that had more than ten
entity instances.
And you can see that we have
over 6,000 different types
that you can draw from.
Uh, over 1,700 of these are in
what we call the commons.
Um, that's an area
that's fairly well protected,
um, community managed,
and curated.
Um, these are the vocabularies
that you can really depend on.
And then we've got,
uh, over 4,000
that are in what we call bases.
Uh, these are areas where
individuals or small communities
are coming together and actually
developing a vocabulary.
So there's a very rich source,
um, of ways
of talking about the entities
that's available to you.
So that we're all using
the same terminology
and so that everybody's clear,
uh, topics are things
that, um, uh, are--are--
topics are objects
that represent things
in the real world.
Um, so for instance,
um, we have a topic
that represents a person--
Jane Austen.
Um, we have topics
that represent places--
um, Steventon,
where she was born.
Uh, and we have topics
that represent other things
in the world,
for instance--
Darcy, one of her characters,
um, other things
like planets and iPods
and things like that, as well.
Uh, what's unique about Freebase
is that all of these, uh, topics
have strong identifiers,
that is, there is a unique,
uh, and dependable way
that you can actually reference,
uh, these objects
by using these identifiers.
But it's important
to keep in mind that objects,
while they have IDs, the IDs
are not actually their names.
Names are actually attributes
on these objects.
So that leads us to properties,
the relationships
between these objects.
And you can see that,
uh, Jane Aun--Jane Austen
influenced Henry James,
and Henry James was influenced
by Jane Austen.
Um, these links
are bidirectional,
but it's important to understand
that the links can have
unique names in each direction.
And finally, this
is really a-a very subtle thing
when you're looking at a graph
of entities.
It's the properties that are
actually creating the meaning.
When you, you know,
think about the object
that represents Jane Austen,
there's nothing intrinsic
about that object
that tells you anything
about Jane Austen.
It's the relationships that
that object has
with other things in the graph,
for instance,
the fact that there's a link
called "place of birth,"
a property called
"place of birth"
that leads you to another object
which is Steventon.
And the fact that there
is a date of birth that's--
leads you to a literal,
which is 1775,
and the fact that she actually
has a name, which is her label--
these are the things that
actually bestow Jane Austen-ness
onto that object.
So now that we have
sort of a-a quick understanding
of sort of what
it is that we're talking about,
um, let's press
right on into the language.
Um, this is MQL,
the Metaweb Query Language,
where we can ask this graph
of entities questions.
We're gonna start off, um, with
a bunch of really simple queries
that I think demonstrate
the different forms
that, uh, queries can take.
So we're just gonna look
at the relationship
between Jane Austen
and her place of birth.
So probably the simplest query
that we could formulate
is to say we're gonna start
with this object, Jane Austen,
and then we're going to look
at this property,
which is, um, ideas, uh,
/people/person/place_of_birth,
and we're gonna say "null,"
that is we want the system
to actually fill in
that last part.
And when we do this
and run the query,
it comes back
with the "label" Steventon.
So, uh, it replaces the null
with just the label
of the entity at the other end.
Now we can be
a little bit more sophisticated
and we can actually say,
"well, we know that the thing
at the other end is an object,"
and so by using
the curly braces,
um, we're actually
going to ask the system
to blow this object out.
And what it gives us back
is all of the sort of core
object properties
that are on the other end.
So for instance,
the fact that it has an ID,
that it has a name,
um, and this object
has a whole bunch
of these different types.
It's, uh, a topic.
It's a location.
It's a city/town,
and there's a bunch more
information that it gives.
Being a little bit
more sophisticated,
we can actually ask a wild card,
um, and the wild card,
um, the star is going to return
us the same information
that we got in the last query,
plus a bunch more information,
um, based on the type of object
that we should be seeing
on the other end of that link.
So here it knows
that, um, place of birth
has a location at the other end,
and so it's going
to give us things
like the containment hierarchy--
the fact that it's contained
by the United Kingdom.
It's contained by Hampshire.
Um, if it had, uh, if it
were in the United States,
it might have a USBG name
associated with it.
So, uh, we can also ask
for a very specific property
off of this
where we just want
the ID of the object
at the other end.
So here we just get back
/en/steventon.
And in this case, I'm actually
gonna turn the query around.
I'm gonna say I know that,
you know,
some people were born
in Steventon.
Um, I'm curious
as to who they are.
And I put this query
in square brackets,
because I know that I'm gonna--
going to possibly get
a list of people back.
And so, in fact, it turns out
that Jane and her siblings
were actually born there--
not terribly surprising.
Uh, we can also, um, reverse
the meaning
of the /people/place_of_birth,
uh, property.
So here I'm saying,
uh, I'm starting on Steventon,
and I know there's links
from other objects
that are place of birth.
Show me what's there.
And, uh, we use
the bang operator in this case
to reverse the meaning
of the property.
And lo and behold,
we actually get Jane
and her siblings back
as well here.
So that's great.
That sort of runs us through
the different forms
that a MQL query can take,
and we'll be using a lot
of those different forms,
uh, as we work through
the rest of this, uh, talk.
Um, but what's really
interesting about Freebase
is the fact
that all of these properties
are in a very orderly
relationship with one another,
and this is what we call schema,
and this is sort of how
to understand what to expect,
um, as you navigate the graph.
And so we can start
with Jane Austen,
and we can say, "How is it
that we actually know
"that Jane Austen is a person?
"And furthermore,
what makes us think
that she actually has this
property 'place of birth'?"
So let's start
with the first question.
And the first thing
to sort of understand
is that everything in Freebase
is represented as an object.
And objects then have a set of
properties associated with them,
and I don't know that you can
necessarily read this,
but the idea is that
there's a reference
that you can go to and you can
see all of the properties
on a type object.
And one of the first things
that you'll probably use,
uh, is the type property.
So that's great.
We know that, um, Jane Austen,
being an object,
she's going to have a type
property associated with her,
and we can actually run
a query to find out
what's at the other end
of that, uh, type link.
And lo and behold, we discover
that there's another object
which has the ID /people/person.
Ah, so this is interesting.
This is how it is that we think
that Jane Austen is a person.
But what's so special about
that /people/person object?
Well, it's an object, so it's
going to have a type link,
and we can run a query there
to find out
what it's connected to,
and what we discover
is, at the other end,
there's another object
called /type/type.
Okay, so that's great.
We have another object there.
Super. Let's play this game out
a little bit further.
Let's run that query again.
And what's special
about /type/type
is that /type/type
is actually connected to itself.
So this sort of completes
the circuit, right?
We actually now understand
how it is that /people/person
became a type
and how it is then that
Jane Austen becomes a person
by being connected
to that object.
So that's cool.
You know, we have
some basic understanding
of sort of how the type system
comes into being in the graph.
Um, but that
still doesn't answer
this--this latter question,
which is,
how is it that we think
that she actually has a property
called "place of birth"?
Well, to do that, we probably
have to look a little bit closer
at this interesting type
called type.
Uh, one of the things to notice
is that types have properties,
so let's go back to our graph.
Um, this is the same triad
that we were just exploring.
Uh, and we know that
there's another type out there
called property,
so that's great.
Um, we know that this object,
which is type property
is actually connected
to /type/type
just like person is--
cool.
Um, and we know that this type
has properties,
and one of those properties
is, uh, a thing
called expected type.
So now we actually have
a property on property,
which is the expected type.
Awesome.
You can see
how this playing out.
So now we can actually go
and construct
a, um, place of birth property.
We connect it up,
because it's a type property.
And we're going to make it
a property of /people/person.
And it actually
has an expected type
of location.
And you can see how this
is all interconnected.
So this is great.
We actually have now
an understanding
of both how types in the system
come into being
and also how properties
are represented in the system
and how they're connected
up to their types.
What's really fun about this
is that all of this is done
in the graph.
And that means that using
our MQL query capabilities
that we've been building up,
we can actually interrogate
these structures
exactly the same way
we've been interrogating,
uh, Jane Austen.
In fact, we can do both
at the same time.
How much fun is that?
So let's play on
and sort of interrogate
the schema a little bit more.
So for this, uh, object out
there which is /people/person,
we know that its type is type,
um, and we want to know
all of the properties
that are on this type.
So, uh, we ask a simple query.
We get back a list
of all of the properties,
including, um, place of birth.
It happens to also have gender
and profession
and a whole bunch
of other things.
Uh, so for this place of birth,
um, we know
that it's a /type/property.
We know that there's a property
called expected_types.
Let's find out
what's at the other--
what we should expect to be at
the other end of these objects.
And that tells us that
it's a location. So great.
So we actually now
can interrogate,
um, that graph structure
that we were looking at before.
So now we can build up slightly
more interesting structures,
and this is a structure
that we're actually
going to refer to again.
Um, we're going to say,
for, uh, some type,
um, I want
all of its properties,
and I want to know
what the expected type is
of those properties.
So, um, find me all of the types
that have properties
where the expected type
is a location.
And what we get back
is, um, the fact
that, uh, the location type has
a property called "contains."
The location property also has
a property called "containedby."
What's kind of interesting
is this is actually what we call
the phylogeny pattern.
These are, um, properties
that expect their own type,
uh, on the other side,
and you can sort of
create hierarchies
and--and circuits that way.
Um, we also get human language
back--
the region of the human language
as a location.
Uh, and lo and behold,
place_of_birth
on /people/person,
uh, has an expected type
of location
as well as a whole bunch
of other ones.
So great.
Now I told you
that, uh, properties,
uh, are bidirectional
and that they have different
names in each direction.
And for the most part, you can
just sort of think of properties
as being sort of uniform.
But it turns out
that, under the surface,
properties actually have
a bit of a directionality
associated with them--
where were they defined,
essentially.
Um, and so here,
I'm asking for,
um, the, uh, in the, uh,
written_work type,
I want to know about
the author property.
And I want to know
if it's a master
or if it's actually
just the inverse
of, uh, another property.
And it turns out that,
when I run this query,
I discover that, in fact, um,
there is a master property,
which is defined on author,
which is the works written.
So this is that link
running in the other direction.
So the only thing
to take away from this
is that there is this notion
of directionality
that's sort of buried
under the covers.
For the most part, you really
don't have to think about it,
but when we're gonna start
playing some of the games
that we're going
to be talking about
a little bit down the road,
um, this is actually
going to come in very handy.
So now that we understand
a little bit more about schema,
how to interrogate it,
um, let's press on,
and actually look
into connections.
Now going back
to that really simple query
that we started with, um, where
we talk about Jane Austen,
this time,
we're actually gonna look at
the languages that she spoke.
Uh, I want to find out what, uh,
languages are at the other end,
and what you discover is that,
um, she actually spoke English,
so that's the little
representation at the bottom.
And what you
have to really think about
when you write
a very simple query like this
is that this
/people/person/languages,
this property
is really representing
this link,
and what you're doing is
you're looking from one object
across to another object,
but what we don't see
is anything
about that link itself.
So happily,
uh, MQL actually provides
a directive called "link"
that we can insert
to actually see
into, uh, the connection
that's being made
between these two objects.
It's not just that we think
that these objects
are sort of nearby.
We think that there's a link,
and we want to know more
about them.
Uh, the link directive
actually returns,
uh, objects of /type/link
and if you look at
the properties for /type/link,
you discover that it has things
like creator and timestamp--
Who did this?
When did they do it?--
as well as a whole bunch
of other properties,
and we're gonna look at those
other properties, actually,
in depth here.
So, um, this
is the, uh, client display
of the schema for a /type/link,
and this is actually one of my
favorite, um, type definitions
in the whole Freebase system,
because I-I think it's just like
the ultimate understatement--
"used to access
the advanced features of MQL."
Tells you nothing!
Um, and yet, all of this power
is hidden away
in these different properties.
Um, so we're going
to explore this, actually,
a-a-a bit in depth.
So these are the properties
of /type/link.
And they actually sort of,
um, form different bundles,
which I think of
as sort of fulfilling
different needs
that you might have,
depending upon sort of what
activity you're engaged in.
So this first set--timestamp,
creator, operation, and valid--
are useful for exploring
the history of these links.
When were these made?
Who did it?
Um, and we can actually
talk about sort of time.
Schema, um, we can look
at the master_property
and the reverse property--
the things
that we were looking at before
when we were looking
at the /book/author.
And finally, uh, source, target,
and target_value--
these are the connections
on each end of the link,
and this is really useful when
we want to reflect on the graph
and understand a lot more
about the connections.
So we'll talk about
each one of these sets,
uh, in depth.
So going back
to, uh, our link directive,
we can actually just add in
the specific property
that we want.
Who is the creator of this link
between Jane Austen
and the English language?
and lo and behold,
you discover that it was me.
Um, now we can play out
a little bit more
of a history, uh, game.
Um, so starting
with Jane Austen,
um, we know
that she's an object,
so she has a bunch of types
associated with her.
And now we actually want
to look at the links
between this Jane Austen
and the different types
that she has.
So here, um, I'm opening up
the--the link there.
I'm asking for the timestamp,
the operation,
whether or not
it was an insert or a delete,
and whether or not this link
is currently valid
in the system.
And finally, I'm gonna actually
sort, um, the output
based on the timestamp
of the link creation,
so I can see these things
in chronological order.
And what we get back, uh,
is actually kind of interesting.
We discover that when
Jane Austen was added,
uh, she was given,
um, the type "common topic,"
that is she became a topic,
um, and that was in,
uh, October of 2006.
And yes, in fact,
it's still true--
she is a topic.
She's also a per--a person,
um, that was added in November
of 2006,
and that link is still valid,
as well.
But then we get to this one,
which is a little perplexing.
It says
that she was a film writer.
The only problem
is that she was long dead
before celluloid was being used
to create motion pictures.
So it's a little hard to imagine
her as being a film writer.
Um, happily, we can see that,
uh, even though this was
inserted in November of 2006,
um, the link
is not currently valid.
And if we look further
and further down the chronology,
we actually discover
that, in fact,
the /film/writer type--the link
to it was actually deleted,
uh, in, uh, what, July of 2010.
So happily, somebody went in
and corrected this,
but we can actually see
all of this history,
and that's because Freebase
is really
an append-only data store.
So we have
all of this information
about what has happened
to these objects over time.
So great.
Uh, that actually sort of
takes us through history.
And now we can look
a little bit more at schema.
Um, so starting with Jane Austen
and looking
at this languages link,
we can ask about,
what is the master property
for this link?
Um, we can also ask
if it's the reverse.
And what we get back is,
in fact, it's not the reverse.
Um, that the master_property
is /people/person/languages,
and you say, "Gee, that's really
not terribly informative,
because that's the way
I asked the query."
And I'm thinking,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's actually more
that we can do here.
So for instance,
if I were actually
sort of building an application,
one of the things I might want
to do
is to say, "Ah, I can actually
open up this link,
"and I can get out the display
name of that property,
"as well as learn about the type
that I should find
at the other end,"
and I can do that all in this
one package, so that's great.
I actually get back to the fact
that the display name
for this link is languages,
um, and the thing that
I should find at the other end
is, uh, a human language.
Now the only problem here
is that it's a little bit
of a cheat.
Um, and that's because,
in fact,
this could have been
the reverse property.
So here's a query where
I'm asking about Ridley Scott,
the director of "Blade Runner"
and other like classics.
Um, and I'm gonna look at him
as a film director
and get back the films
that he's connected to.
And here I'm asking for the link
between Ridley Scott
and his films, and I'm gonna
get back the master_property,
the display name,
the expected_type,
and now I'm actually asking
for the reverse
of that master_property,
so I'm gonna find out
what that property definition is
going in the other direction.
And I'm gonna get the name
and the expected_type.
And you'll see
this "reverse": null down here,
um, is actually very important,
because now
when it comes back true,
that tells my application
that I should actually be
looking at this area in green
and using that
as the information
about this link.
Make sense? Cool.
Okay, just to make sure
I'm not, you know, pulling
the wool over your eyes here.
Um, so this is great.
So now we can actually formulate
sort of meaningful queries.
We can get
a lot of information back
about the links
that are in those queries.
Um, but, you know,
there's this one sort of thing
when we're actually
exploring the graph,
and that is, if I'm just looking
at an object,
how is that I can know
what queries
I should actually be asking?
How do I know what things
are actually connected to this?
Um, and in fact,
this is the mechanism
that the Freebase client
actually uses
to display the information
about these topics
and help you navigate
around the graph.
So we're gonna look at,
uh, again, uh, /type/link,
and the last set here--
source, target, and value--
to understand how it is that
we can reflect on these things.
Source, target is the idea
that these links
have a source--
they start somewhere
and they end in another place,
and sometimes that thing
that they end on
is actually a literal value,
oh, or a primitive value
of some sort.
So that's what source, target--
source, target, and target_value
are giving you.
So we can formulate
a pretty simple query,
which is, um, we're going
to use /type/link.
We want to start with the source
of being Jane Austen.
We want to get the property
that connects Jane Austen
to other things, which, on
the other side, are just topics.
Cool. This is a nice
little reflect query.
And we can find out that,
in fact,
she has a master_property
of place of birth
and that the target
is en/Steventon,
uh, and that,
uh, she has a place of death,
whichwas Winchester,
uh, and that she has gender,
and she is female,
and it goes on and on--
all of the things that
are connected up to Jane Austen.
So that's cool.
Um, but there's really more
to this story
that we need to unpack.
And so one of the things,
when you're exploring,
uh, Freebase schema--
um, and you could to go
the client and do this,
but since we actually know
how to write MQL queries
against schema,
we can actually write our own--
and that is, can we actually
find a property
that has the expected type
of /type/link on property?
And lo and behold,
there is, happily,
a thing called, uh, links,
which is all of the uses
of this property.
And, uh, now I can say something
like, for the property
"place of birth,"
I want to get back
all of the links that are--
all of the connections
that are using this property.
And the first one I get back
actually was made
by a guy named Robert.
Uh, it was the source
of Steve Martin
and connecting him to Waco,
uh, and that was done
in December of 2006,
and it's currently valid,
so apparently
that's the right thing to say.
So this is great.
So we actually have a way now
of exploring all of the uses
of a property.
And that's kind of important,
because in that query
that we ran for Jane Austen,
the reflect query,
where we said that Jane Austen
was the source,
and we wanted to know
the target,
that tells us this story.
It says Jane Austen
is connected to Steventon,
and she's connected
to the English language,
to "Pride and Prejudice."
But what's missing is the fact
that actually Henry James
is connected to Jane Austen,
but the connection
is going the other direction.
Jane Austen is the target
of that connection.
She's not the source.
So that's simple enough to fix.
We could actually just say,
"well, we're gonna run the query
"that we ran before
where Jane Austen is the source,
and we're looking
for the target."
We could run another query
where we actually say,
"Hey, uh, Jane Austen
is the target.
Show me the source."
That would get us back
to Henry James. Cool.
But that seems
really kind of inefficient.
So let's take another approach
given sort of all the mechanism
that we now have under our belt.
We can start
with this very simple query,
which says
for this object Jane Austen,
give me back all of her types,
that is all of the types
that Jane Austen is using.
And for every one
of those types,
go to the schema and tell me
all of the properties
that those types have.
So we run this, and we get back
all of the properties
for all of those types.
Now we can actually use
that links property
on property,
and we can say,
"Great, for all the uses
of that property,
"show me where Jane Austen
is the source.
Find me all of the targets."
And that's essentially the same
as our first reflect query,
but we can extend this
even further,
and we can now reverse it.
And we can say, "Look,
for the use of--of--of this
as the master_property," which
means going the other direction,
"um, I want to find all
of the links for that property,
um, where we want the source
and Jane Austen is the target."
Cool. This give us
sort of full reflection.
So now we have a way
of actually picking up an object
in the graph
and knowing everything there
is to know about that object.
And so once you have
this capability then,
I think,
um, this really sort of suggests
a new style of programming
when you're thinking about
working with Freebase data,
and that is to act
on the meaning
that you get back
from the objects in the graph.
So the typical approach,
and the approach
that we've been sort of
playing out earlier in this talk
was to say, well, we start
with an object like Jane Austen,
we say, "Great,
we know that she is a person,
and she has a place of birth,"
and then we go on and we say,
"Great, we think
that she has some languages.
Give us those languages."
And there's a whole bunch
of other stuff
that we probably want.
"You know, she's an author.
Tell us about her books"
and things like that.
And so great, we, you know,
do some "collabor-optomization."
We, I don't know,
package these things up.
We write a whole bunch
of optional clauses,
or we package these up
in one MQL envelope
to make the transport
more efficient,
but when we take
that kind of rote approach,
things go a little bit south
when we actually have
another person like Franz Liszt,
right?
Not an author, a composer.
We probably want to ask slightly
different questions about him.
How are we gonna do that?
Well, if we go back and use
our reflect capabilities,
We can write a query
essentially like this.
We probably want to expand it
in some interesting ways,
but this is the basic skeleton
that you would be using,
and now you're going to get back
all of the things
that are connected
to that object, Franz Liszt,
and we're gonna learn
that he's a composer.
And now the trick is to say,
can your application
take the results of this query
and respond to those
in useful ways?
So if I want to sort of respond
to him as a person,
I could write
a bunch of functions
that deal with the properties
coming off of here as a person
to represent him as a person.
If I think that composers
are important,
I can go and add some
more methods around composers
to the system without
ever having to change the query.
And the important thing
to understand
is that Freebase
is a very live community, right?
The graph
is continually changing.
New connections are being made
to objects.
New types and new properties
are coming into existence
every day.
If you have to go in
and actually modify the queries
and modify the code
that's digesting those queries
and taking them apart
and finding all the results,
that's a lot of work.
Much easier to write sort of
a straightforward query
that grabs all the information
that it can
and then sends it off
for processing
in the applications, so that you
get some useful results back.
So this is great.
I think, you know, this is--
this really does suggest
sort of this
property-driven programming.
I see the property,
I respond to it, in which case,
my application has really become
sort of semantically aware.
That is, I'm responding
to the meaning of these objects
in interesting ways.
But that's actually, I think,
just sort of the first part
of the story.
Metaschema is the idea
that there are generalized
relationships in Freebase.
So, for instance, if we think
about Jane Austen
and her relationship
to Steventon,
we can say, well, that's not
just her place of birth,
but that's in some sense,
the origin of Jane Austen.
And similarly, we could look at
her book, "Pride and Prejudice,"
and we could say its place
of first publication--
that property points to London,
but we could also think of that
as being the PlaceOfOrigin
for the book.
So now we have one property
which actually describes
two properties.
And so, if we actually respond
to PlaceOfOrigin
in some interesting way,
now we actually
have some leverage.
We can actually
group properties together
write a bunch of methods
against, uh, these,
and we'll get sort of more power
out of our application.
One of the nice things about
metaschema is it actually isn't,
uh, just sort of single-property
relationships, as well.
In Freebase, when you represent
the relationship
of an actor to the film,
for instance, Colin Firth
to the BBC miniseries
"Pride and Prejudice,"
there's actually
an intermediate node there,
which is the performance,
and that performance
is necessary
because we need to be able
to tell you that on that path
between "Pride and Prejudice"
and Colin Firth,
he actually played
a role of Darcy,
and we need a place to actually
hang that property,
and that's gonna come off
of the performance.
But in sort of a colloquial way,
it would be nice
to be able to say,
oh, Colin For--Firth
was an actor
in "Pride and Prejudice,"
as opposed to actually saying,
well, he was
in this performance,
and that performance
was for this movie.
So one of the nice things
is that metaschema
actually allows us to jump over
relationships, as well.
So now we can actually have
a HasContributor relationship
between Colin Firth
and the BBC production
of "Pride and Prejudice."
So we went through
the whole graph,
and we looked at
all of the properties
in Freebase commons,
and what we discovered
was that about 3,500
of the properties
actually fell into
one of 46 patterns,
and those 46 patterns
package those 3,500 properties
in interesting sort of,
um, stylistic patterns.
And, of course, what fun
would this mapping
of those 3,500 properties
into 46 patterns be
if we didn't actually go
and represent that
in the graph itself,
so that you could query it?
So that mapping,
uh, into all of these properties
into those patterns,
is actually represented in what
we call this metaschema schema.
And it's actually very simple.
I won't go into the details
here, but the idea is
that you can start with
something like a property,
/film/director/film,
and you can ask what it--
the relationship is,
what is the predicate, the type
of relationship that it has?
And we can actually use
that little query snippet,
um, in our Jane Austen query
about what properties
are on these types,
and we're gonna get back, then,
all of the different patterns
of the different properties
that are on those types.
So with Jane Austen,
this isn't actually
terribly interesting, right?
I mean, what we really know
about Jane Austen
is that she was an author.
Yeah, that's great.
I mean, very important author
and she's really fun to read,
but she's not that challenging
to actually represent.
But when it comes to somebody
like Robert Redford,
things go a little bit
weird, right?
I mean, he's an actor,
but we actually represent
the fact that he's a film actor
and a TV actor and a stage actor
all separately.
But yet, if our application
is responding to meaning,
it would be nice to actually
group those things together,
so we can play out that
same query using Robert Redford,
and what we discover
is, in fact,
we get a much fewer
set of predicates
than we do of all the properties
that, uh, he is actually
connected to.
So we can actually add
this little, um, snippet
into our reflection,
and now when we look
at the connections
between Jane Austen
and all of the other objects,
we can get those relationships
back now as metaschema,
as one of these 46 patterns.
So the idea here is really to
reduce the number of properties
that your program
has to respond to,
needs to understand
in some sense.
We said that Freebase has
a really rich set of vocabulary,
and that's absolutely true,
but the question is, you know,
would you really like
to have to go and map all of
those properties into methods,
or would you actually
like to say, well, there are
kind of these 46 patterns
that I'm interested in,
and there are some
very specialized things
that I want to do,
perhaps, around people?
Um, or, you know, whatever it is
that my domain of interest is,
but the rest of them,
I can sort of group into
these larger collections
and respond to in aggregate.
So that was sort of
a whirlwind tour through this.
What I wanted to do, since we
have a little bit of time,
uh, is to show you
uh, a very bad application,
and I would not suggest that,
um, that this is a framework
in any way.
It's just an idea out there
that you can sort of look at
and try to understand
what's going on.
Um, so this
not-pretty application
is designed for you to clone--
um, it is--
I tried to be as bare-bones
about things as possible,
so that you could actually see
what was going on.
Um, and so, in this--oops.
Uh, I can ask for,
uh, Jane Austen...
Oops.
Apparently, hard--
hard to see
what's going on over there.
There we go.
And what I have
is just, uh, two methods
in this application,
which are responding to,
um, the results
of the reflect query,
so this is a very bare-bones
template to display things.
In fact, all of the juice
is in this,
um, one function here,
reflection,
so I go to doreflect,
and look at this,
and this is just going through
and actually running
the reflect query,
and then dispatching into
a bunch of functions
that I've defined,
um, for the different properties
that I get back,
and I have
a very minimal collection
of these properties,
or these functions,
so I have something
for common_topic_alias.
You saw that
with George Washington.
And I'm saying,
if there's an image,
show us the image, as well.
Now that wasn't too interesting
for, uh, Jane Austen,
and let me show you,
uh, what happens if we do...
Ridley Scott.
Here, we see the alias
and the images coming back.
Again, not terribly exciting.
But if we wanted to do something
more interesting
for Ridley Scott, say,
I could add a function in
which interprets
the, uh, relationship
between a film director
and his films,
and so I'll add
this very simple one in.
It just goes off and gets
the picture of the film
at the other end of the link.
Go back and refresh.
And now actually, I'm
interpreting all of the other--
The query hasn't changed at all.
Same information coming back.
I'm just dispatching on another
property, so this is great.
I've got more information
about the films
that he's directed here.
Um, but, uh...
Let's see. If I do
Jane Austen again,
just to sort of prove
that I'm not doing anything
too magical here...
Um, this doesn't help
Jane Austen at all, right?
She's not a film director.
Okay, so great.
Let's actually go and turn this
into a bit of metaschema,
so down here,
I've added a function
for ContributedTo,
which is one of the properties
that I'll get back,
uh, and then if I go and--
it turns out that this reflect
query and this metareflect query
are literally the same
except for that one clause,
but unfortunately, I didn't want
to try to edit it on the fly
since I'm really bad
at the keyboard,
uh, and I will just change
the query that I'm using
to metareflect.
Now if we look at Jane Austen,
we discover
that she has contributed
to a whole bunch of films.
She's credited as the
story writer for these films,
not--not the screenwriter,
uh, as well as a whole bunch
of information
about books and things
like that,
um, and if I go in
and actually look
at Ridley Scott again...
What I get back is not only
the films that he directed,
but he also has produced
a bunch of films
and acted as, you know,
ancillary personnel on films,
and so we get a whole lot
more information
about the films
that he's worked on.
And, of course,
if we were really clever,
we could actually
display the property
that was contributing to this
metaschema relationship
and things like that.
But the idea is that this
is a really simple pattern
which takes that one query now
and allows you to do
a whole lot of stuff with it,
and allows you to incrementally
change your application
to respond to the data
that's coming back.
Um, so this is online,
and if you go to the, um,
there's...
Let's see here.
If you go to
io2011.freebaseapps.com,
um, all of the queries that
I went through today are there,
as well as a link
to that application,
which you can clone,
uh, and modify
and play with yourself,
and then there's information
about Freebase documentation.
All of the things
that I've been telling you
are in that documentation,
and we have a very active
developer community.
Um, the Freebase mailing list,
um, you can find out about it
at lists.freebase.com.
So I'm happy
to entertain questions,
comments.
Happily, I left about as much
time as I had hoped for.
All right.
[applause]
man: This may be
a silly 101 question,
but what's the relationship
between the data that's
in Freebase right now
and, say, other source data
like Wikipedia
or census data
or stuff like that?
Taylor: Right, so Freebase
is a super-set
of a lot of different data sets,
um, so we're continuously
importing Wikipedia,
uh, mostly for
the topics themselves.
Um, and I'm not sure what
the total article count
in Wikipedia is these days,
but it's, I believe,
well under 4 million,
so given the 22 million
that's in Freebase,
um, it's a pretty, you know,
small section.
It's an important section,
um, but it's a subset of--
We have other data sets,
like MusicBrainz is brought in,
um, for a lot of music data.
It's augmented by a lot
of other sources, as well,
so Freebase is really,
in some sense, the melting pot
for all of these
different data sets.
And one of the important things,
um, is you can think
about Freebase
as sort of the Rosetta stone
for navigating between
these different data sets,
because all of their
sort of internal identifiers
are actually maintained
with the Freebase topics,
so that you can actually use
a Wikipedia article name,
come into Freebase,
and find the topic that
that's associated with,
and then jet out to another
data source, um, as well.
So it's--that's one
very important way
of actually using Freebase.
man: I'm curious how and if MQL
handles transitive predicates.
Taylor: Ahh.
man: And, uh, in terms of
querying either n-hops
or, uh infinite hops,
and within the topic.
Taylor: Yeah, so we--
MQL does not actually have
any transitive operations,
so it's up to you
to navigate
those links yourself.
man: Okay, thanks.
man: I know Google
just recently put out
a whole lot of
the U.S. Patent Office online.
Is there any chance
of getting this integrated?
Taylor: Uh, you know, I think
it really depends
on sort of the interest
of the community,
um, but, yes, we've actually--
people have added
patent models before
in hopes that we could actually
do that type of thing.
I don't know
of any current plans,
but I think it's
a pretty interesting idea.
man: So my question
centers around
using MQL outside of Freebase.
Obviously, it's a very
expressive syntax,
and it would be very good
for other APIs,
so my question is,
do you have any advice on--
um, is it very feasible
to be able to,
um, incorporate the same syntax
and, like, what's some
good things to read?
Taylor: So this has actually
come up on the mailing list,
uh, in the past,
and we know of actually
at least two other
MQL implementations
that are out there.
Um, there's a geo data set
and another knowledge base
that is actually using,
essentially, MQL syntax.
In fact, the geo dataset--
um, their documentation
just pointed to ours.
Um, they had
very specific things,
but the actual MQL syntax
and things like that,
they wanted you to actually
look at sort of this one source.
And we'd be, you know,
very interested and excited
to see other people adopting it.
I don't have anything specific
to say about the implementation.
I'm not sort of in that world,
but I know that, you know,
there are actual papers
that have been published
on, like graphd, the underlying
data store and things like that,
so I'm sure if you asked,
you know, hard questions
that you might have,
on the mailing list,
somebody would probably
be interested in talking.
man: Uh, hi. Thanks for
your presentation.
Uh, so are there
any uses of Freebase
that are not permitted?
Basically, is there
an open license?
Can Freebase be integrated
into commercial applications?
Are there different
content licenses?
Do people own what they put
into Freebase? Et cetera.
Taylor: Yeah, so that's
a great question.
Um, so everything that's
in Freebase in the graph
is available under a Creative
Commons Attribution license,
and you're free to use that
however you want
in your own applications,
commercial or otherwise.
The data--
things like the images,
um, and some of
the article descriptions,
are under other open licenses,
and you can actually
get that information.
You need to make
the proper attribution
if you're using those things
that are coming out of what
we call the blob store,
um, but there's also--
and I didn't put it up there.
It's in the documentation--
um, the data dumps,
which is a very popular way
of consuming the data en masse
if you're going to do
processing on it
for different applications,
so those are being produced
on a very regular basis,
so you can actually
look through the whole graph,
extract the information
that you're interested in,
and use it, uh, with
the proper attributions.
Great. Well, I really appreciate
all of the questions
and comments,
and feel free to contact me if
you have any further thoughts.
Thank you.
[applause]